my opinion on the legalization of
marijuana is complicated because when we
think about a society in general if we
think about these things honestly every
society has their intoxicant we have
alcohol that's our primary when we also
have tobacco and we have caffeine which
is not as intoxicating now the question
becomes should we make another
intoxicant legal now we know all the
problems that we have with those with
alcohol tobacco and caffeine we know the
problems that we may have so that means
if you have marijuana be more widely
available you can also expect to maybe
have some more problems some of those
similar types of problems on the one
hand on the other hand in New York City
for example we're arresting hundreds of
thousands of people every year for
marijuana and they have they as a result
they have a record or they have some
sort of blemish and that might retard
their ability to make a contribution so
we are also having some consequences
from our current legal status of the
drug so the society has to balance what
is more important to the society but
they should do so with their eyes open
you will have problems either way but
the point becomes which problems are we
willing to tolerate as a society on the
one hand now that's the legalization
issue that you're talking about that's a
more availability now when we think
about medical marijuana the Institute on
medicine did a report that tried to
study this issue comprehensively and
suggested that we should probably
continue to investigate therapeutic
potential to therapeutic potential of
marijuana and that's that clearly
support that position that we certainly
need to if people are suffering and we
have potential medications that will
help relieve their suffering absolutely
we should go full forth with that and we
should do it in a responsible
way in which in a similar way in which
we look at in which we use drugs like
morphine which is essentially heroin we
we do that responsibly
and we certainly do it in a restricted
and a controlled manner and we should
probably do the same with